hi all so
um I will
share my screen
um
and
so
um I'm yours from Boston I'm
um
I'm one of the
um maintainers of pandas
um I think you should be seeing my
slides now
um
so
I'll set up
um
yeah involved in in several open source
packages among others pandas and um I'm
also working at Voltron data where we
um
are working on
um where I'm working on the Apache Arrow
open source project and mostly the by
Arrow bindings but this talk is not
about Arrow it's about pandas and so
the title is about copies and Views that
uh is also about the setting with copy
warning and um
I think most people if you have used
pandas you will probably have run into
this warning uh this setting setting
with copywriting and value is trying to
be set on a copy of a slice of it from a
data frame
um I'm not sure how many people uh
if they see that running really know
what is going on or what your reaction
generally is it might be something like
this
that you think what what is this uh I
don't know I just yeah
run away ignore it I don't know but it's
in any case a topic that
um yeah that also uh causes quite some
um uh
attraction let's say it's like that so
there are a lot of blog posts like
trying to explain what the warning is
how you can how to understand it how to
get rid of it so I just from Google here
are a few uh blog posts examples that
are like go into detail on this setting
with copy warning
um how to fix how to fix it
um
and Etc and so
setting with copywriting is about copies
and Views so as a starter for this
presentation
um a very brief
primer on on a copy or a few so assume
that you have a data frame so uh df1 and
you see this on the left so you have a
data frame one and if you have a second
data frame df2 that is a view of the F
of the First Data frame that means that
under the hood the actual data of your
um
of your data frame the the numpy arrays
the the arrays the the those are shared
that they are pointing to the same
memory well if you make a copy of a of
the First Data frame into a second data
frame as this picture on the right then
it's not pointing to the same data and
when is this relevant it's relevant when
you are mutating when you're
changing values in your data frame so
for example if you are here
mutating either
um
tf1 or df2 let's assume df2 here
in the first case when df2 is a view of
the First Data frame
they are both updated while on the in
the case on the right
if you update df2 there and it was a
copy the First Data frame was not
updated so it matters it has impact on
actual behavior
and to give a few examples
um here like the first example that we
have here is I have a small data frame
um that I that was created here uh just
three columns
you create a subset of that data frame
and in this case I'm doing a filter
operation like select all the rows of my
data frame there
in this case column A is larger than one
if you later on
would modify this subset this filter
data frame you get this setting with
copy running because it might not have
updated uh the the First Data frame so
the question here is
if you want to understand what is
happening like
by updating my subset data frame did
also the original data frame DF change
um
so in this case it actually didn't
but let's let's look at let's look at
another example so the same concept but
here instead of doing a filter operation
I sliced the data frame and so what did
happen here
uh in this case this operation would
have updated the First Data frame
yet another case in this case
um
I'm not filtering or slicing rows but
I'm selecting a few columns so
we'll uh will DF change if I if I mutate
subset
in this case that's not the case
um
final example
in this case I'm selecting a single
column out of my data frame
same question here in this case yes if I
mutate this subset the original DF will
also have changed
um and so
this is yeah
there are some problems with
um this this uh this current
um
situation it's confusing
um I think most people uh most users of
pandas won't have been able to guess
exactly uh in all the cases that I've
shown that would have been the correct
answer
um to be able to answer those
um questions to know what what will
happen you actually need to be aware of
how
um copy views work in numpy and how
pandas uses those copy view rules
because
just to give to give
one example
um the difference between the filtering
rows and the slicing rows is because
in numpy the first is a fancy indexing
and will always create new data while
slicing an array gives a view in numpy
so as a user you need to be aware of
those differences when something is if
you run into the copy and as a result
you will also see that a lot of people
who just add a lot of copies to their to
their quotes
um as a small example so
um
another aspect that is very confusing is
that if you do
change set item that it might or might
not work so in this case again I have
here a small data frame and I want to
update the values in the column C
where the values in another column are
larger than one it's a I mean it's a
small dummy not very useful operation
but assume that we want to do this
we can do this in two ways if you do
change assignments
um and the one works in the other notes
the reason for this is that if you write
the second case that one that doesn't
work
um
first assigned this to a temporary
variable and then
updating the column here
then you can see that this is very
similar to the case the example that I
showed before an example where the
original data frame doesn't get updated
um
what do you have to do
um in this case and it's a bit
overlapping with my uh
my uh
my image I see but in general you need
to use
[Music]
um
yeah the
it's it's repeated here
um so how can you avoid this confusion
that the Run works and the other knots
and
avoid taking the warning so if you if
your goal was to update the original
data frame
um you shouldn't do this with chained
assignment so you should always try to
avoid these changed assignments but you
do this assignment step in one go using
that lock where you pass the
both the row and the column selection
in one go to Dot Lock instead of doing
this with a change uh is assignment
or alternatively not use Dot Lock or dot
or get item at all and you can also use
the assignment where you can uh over
overwrite an existing column within yeah
with a calculation
um
that's if you wanted to update your
original data frame but assuming you
actually didn't want to update your
original data frame and just get this
warning
then often people will add a copy like I
just copy my data after that after I
filtered my data after I created my
subset I add a copy so I don't get this
one
um and that works
the downside of this is that you are
adding unnecessary copies often because
in for example in this case where you do
a Boolean filter operation the data was
actually already copied by the operation
and so the additional copy is just a
um yeah an unnecessary copy that
you only had to avoid a binding so
that's something that yeah that is not
ideal Behavior
um so to illustrate this this uh
defensive copying in another way so one
aspect is that people will manually do
this
um the second aspect is also that
um
in pandas itself we already do a lot of
those copies as well if you do if you
use methods on a data frame
and to illustrate this this is a tweet
is not readable but it's a tweet from
Matt Harrison who uh yeah works a lot on
pandas education educational materials
and he uses a lot of method chains and
so I I took a small
um simplified version of of a method
chaining operation from his streets
where we have
um a data frame we rename some columns
we assign uh so we add some new columns
based on the existing columns with the
assign methods we do some type
conversions like convert something to
category drop some columns drop some
rows finally reset the index because we
want to have again a default index and
so
although this seems like a very
um yeah nice and efficient method chain
when it comes to copies there are a lot
of those steps that actually make a copy
of the full data frame while it's not
necessarily needed so
all the steps that I now highlighted are
steps that will actually copy the data
frame
in case of of dropping columns it also
copies The Columns that you are not
dropping in case of as type of course
the column that your chain for which
you're changing the type that's normal
but also the other columns get copied
assign the same The Columns that you
don't touch they get copied
um
people might sometimes use the in Place
keyboard but generally that's something
that we also don't recommend and
might plan to to deprecate
um so
it's confusing it's difficult to know
what what happens it's you you get a lot
of defensive copying so can we do better
and we have been working in in pandas in
the in the
um in the in the contributor Community
I've been working on
um yeah developing a proposal to
simplify this and the summary of this
proposal is that
um
have a single uh simplified rule
where that any data frame or series
derived from another behaves as a copy
so
this derived from another means that if
you if you do a methods for example here
the df.rename will return a new data
frame
currently it's a copy
that's already the behavior but here we
says it behaves as a copy so
we we ensure that it behaves as a copy
but under the hood we can try to
optimize this
um method chaining currently already
copies a lot so this would allow us to
avoid those copies
for indexing operations like the
selecting filtering rows slicing rows
selecting columns there there are
currently some ways that either return a
view or a copy and the proposal here
would be that those all
behave as a copy so again it will allow
from a user point of view look like a
copy but under the hood we might still
use views to optimize the memory usage
um yeah putting this Sim this this one
rule a bit differently so that means
that if you would want to mutate a
certain data frame you can only so
mutate mutilating a data frame like what
we have seen with Dot Lock and then
assign something will only mutate the
data frame itself that where you're
calling the Dot Lock
um it also means if you want to update
values in the data frame you can only do
that by directly muting in this data
frame so we will never have the
situation where updating one data frame
might update another data frame or
series or the other way around
some advantages I think and and that's
one of the goals that it will provide a
simpler or consistent user experience
um we
um
can get rid of the setting with copy
running because there is no like there
are clear rules there is no uh confusion
anymore and we can avoid a lot of those
copies
to give
to get back to the uh to illustrate this
more consistent user experience let's go
back to the examples that I showed
before so
filtering my data frame uh with a with a
Boolean mask
will if I update subset now will it also
change DF
the answer is simple now no because
subset is a different object so
mutating subset will only change subset
and never another data frame so DF will
not be changed
the same thing here if I slice rows
slice rows and then mutate these subsets
same thing the original data frame will
not change because it's a different
object and those are so the subset
behaves as a copy of DF
this was a case where originally the
answer was yes because the slice gives a
view
um
under the hood we will still use a view
but for towards the user the behavior
they observe is that it behaves as a
copy
um same thing here for getting columns
it will not update the original one by
changing the subsets the same for a
single column
the exact same answer
so
yeah
that would the goal is here to simplify
uh those yeah expectations from users
what they can expect from their code
um
second thing as I mentioned we can get
rid of this setting with copy warning
um because the the
um
the case that I showed before where if
you do change assignments
then one option currently works the
other doesn't work depending on the
order that you do your operations
um with the with the proposal neither of
them will work because also in the first
case here
um you're selecting a series and this
will also behave as a copy so further
mutating this series in Van Gogh will
not update the parent data frame
um and again the answer here is if you
want to update apparent data frame don't
use change assignment use Dot Lock or
the assign method
um
so change the signage will never work so
we don't need a warning about it and we
can actually to avoid that people still
try to do this inside and you get no
results we can actually raise an error
for that
um
in addition you also don't need to add
this copy to avoid
the setting with copywriting in cases
where you yeah currently
um got this warning but you you just
wanted to get rid of it so you don't no
longer need those unnecessary copies
um
also in pandas itself all those methods
that currently return on a copy
we can also under the hoods let it
return actually a view
um but ensuring that it behaves as a
copy and that's how how we do that under
the routine panel so how can we
still use under the hood
that let it behave as a copy for the
user and that's uh what what we have uh
what is called copy on right it's a term
that is also used in in other contexts
but the idea is that
whenever you modify certain objects
um
we keep track well so if you create a
new object from another we keep track of
that it's whether it's viewing another
data frame or not and if you then mutate
that data frame it will see ah I'm
actually a viewer on our data frame but
I want the user wants to update values
in my data frame so to ensure the
guarantee that I behave as a copy I will
only I will copy the data only at that
point so only when an actual mutation
happens
um only then
we perform the copy to ensure that it
behaves as a copy but as long as the
user doesn't do any operation that
mutates values in place we don't have to
do this copy already so we can delay the
copy until it's needed
um
so that's a small example here if I
select multiple columns from my data
frame I get a subsets
so
initially this can be a view on the
original columns
but once you would mutate the subset for
example I have this log operation
then we make a copy of the column that
you mutated
to guarantee the behavior that it
behaves as a copy
getting back to this method chaining
example
so also here all those method scan under
the hood avoid making the copy
with the same mechanism the same copy on
that mechanism
so
um that's in summary the The Proposal
um it's important to indicate so that
this is
um not yet the behavior in panels it's
proposed Behavior but it's actively
being worked on uh so you can actually
try it out if you have uh pandas the
latest version of pandas installs so you
need at least Spanish 1.5 and there you
can enable it using an option so the
code snippet that you see here on the
slides with the pd.options dot mode dot
copy on right you can set that to true
and then
um you have to do that in the beginning
and then uh whenever you
um create a data frame or read some data
those data frames will use this new copy
on right behavior and so
it's certainly welcome to try this out
and and provide some uh provide feedback
you can it's at the moment not yet uh
very much very well documented but you
can find some more information about
um
uh yeah but I but I try to explain in in
in a short presentation here in in the
following links so there is a blog post
about it the the detailed proposal
um
um has a lot of detail as well as the
this the the GitHub issue that is linked
here on the slides
um if you want to have those
um links you can find them on uh the
slides and those slides you can uh find
on this link so that's the the easiest
way to to get to the uh the slides on uh
the links on my slides so that was in
summary uh
um yeah a brief presentation of one of
the changes that we are working on in
panus
um
I'm happy to to answer any questions if
there are
uh thank you so much George oh we do
have a question down there from Prince
Francesco isn't the always copy approach
non-python pie funny why don't you let
the user decide to explicitly copy as it
would happen for a python object
um so the
um
one is that uh to the we can't
um let the user decide that themselves
in all cases so that's one problem with
with uh with that is that depending on
the operation you do you already get a
copy or a view anyway because of
the underlying behavior for example like
uh like a Boolean mask is always a copy
a slice can be a few and so if you leave
it up to the user they need to know
those details like when is something of
you when is something a copy and that's
something that we would like to avoid
and make it make it simpler
um
I also don't think that it's necessarily
non-pythonic what is being proposed here
it's it's uh it's break it's um
different compared to numpy
um
because numpy is very much this this
concept of of use and it's a very
important aspect of what makes numpy
efficient and we are also still making
use of that under the hoods it just uh
hidden for pandas users for the direct
users of pandas but if you compare it
for example to
um to python this this actually quite
similar uh what you are doing here if
you slice a python list it's actually a
copy and not a view in contrast to
vampire race so you could in some ways
say that it's making the data frame more
like
python instead of like numpy
yeah you seem to have suddenly muted
I
do you hear me uh I can now
I did did you hear my answer to the
question or
oh yes we got that most of it just like
the tiny bitter that except for like a
tiny bit of the tail end
all right uh we have another one from uh
looks like levitch CEO uh one could
argue that not having to care about
memory is about as pythonic as it gets
uh more
more of a statement I guess
yeah and and yeah I personally um
well I agree with that or at least I
think that
um that's what we want for the majority
of pandas users like uh for most of them
they shouldn't have to care about this
and we need to ensure that for the
minority that maybe wants to really
optimize something exactly and that we
still give the tools to control some of
the details of this behavior
um but uh the idea of The Proposal is
that for yeah majority of of the users
the default behavior that we that that
is in this proposal yeah is is what they
want and they don't have to further care
about it
foreign
we're coming up into the end uh is there
anything you else you'd like to add
um I think just that yeah um you can
already try it out in the latest version
of panda so feedback is very much
appreciated